[Music]
and next please join me in welcoming
daniel falbell from our studio
[Applause]
hello i'm daniel and today i'm going to
talk about
what's new in tensorflow for r
and first a quick recap on what's
tensorflow and well tensorflow is an
open source platform for
machine learning it's especially useful
for deep learning so it has
fast implementations of most common
operations in deep learning like
convolutions for example
and it's very efficient for
both cpus gpus and even tpus which is
the
google hardware for deep learning
it provides automatic differentiation
which
also very useful for deep learning and
it's really production ready so
inside the tensorflow ecosystem
there are multiple ways to deploy your
models to
uh even mobile devices
uh cloud platforms and all of this
uh well tensorflow is a
is mostly a python project with
a lot of uh things in the ecosystem
and i'm going to talk about the
tensorflow for our
package and we are
spread across multiple our packages
there is the tensorflow our package
which is
provides mostly the basic
access to the texture flow model and
installation functions and things like
this
there is the keras our package which
wraps the tf.keras model
which uh the recommended way to start
using tensorflow it's like a higher
level api to use tensorflow
and tf data sets which wraps the tf.data
model
which use use it to load and pre-process
that
data for deep learning and we have a lot
of
other packages in the the ecosystem
system like tf hub tf probability
tfds cf photograph and autocads
which i'm going to talk about so what's
new
there's a lot of package and things are
moving
fast so we have
support for tensorflow 2.0
so before uh
2.0 you needed to tensorflow was
uh worked like you have to define all
your
graph of computation and then you
executed it and this is a programming
model
that is hard to think about usually
and with tf 2.0
it's much easier because of the eager
execution
so before you needed to write code like
this
so you you write all computation and
then you
executed it and now it it works
just like a normal art
arrays other changes in
2.0 are like api cleanup and
things like this
there is this new package by thomas
kalinowski
which is called tf autograph which
allows us to write
conditional loops and
like if and why and four statements
just like an an art if statement which
is
much easier and this is very efficient
also like
for tensorflow so before you needed to
write code like this
with like all all
functional conditionals and now you you
can just write
an if statement and it will be converted
to tensorflow code
in tf data sets which allows to
load and pre-process that data we have
this new feature spec
interface and this is useful for
tableau data and for using tableau data
in deep learning models
so each it works like uh
it has a similar uh interface
to like recipes the tidy models package
and so you just define what
transformations you want to do
on your tablet data and then you fit
this specification which means it will
find all
possible vocabulary and like scaling
all find the normalizing constants for
your numeric variables for example and
then you can just use these
layer dance features uh
function in keras and it this will
[Music]
uh make all the transformations directly
on the tensorflow
graph so it's it's much easier to deploy
this kind
this kind of models
next we have some minor changes in tf
data sets
like if you ever use it
data set map you needed to write a
function
to like per map and now you can use the
per style
lambda functions which like simplifies a
bit
the the code
and you can also pass if you
use it df data sets before you needed to
use the make iterator one shot function
to
create an iterator for your diet for
your tensorflow data set
and now you can pass this directly to
keras and
it will just work
another cool new package is the tf
hub package with that which allows us to
use
any mod any pre-trained models from the
this website here tfhub.dev
and in so
people train their models in large
data sets and and provide them the
pre-trained models
in a useful format and then you can just
use it as a new keras layer so
you have an the url for a model
in this case it's the mobile net model
and you use you have this layer hub
function that just takes the model url
and then so
this model is taking an image and
returning
a feature vector representing this image
and you can just plug a dense layer for
example to make a
classification use this pre-trained
using these pre-trained
pre-trained models it also includes
models for text and video
tf-hub also provides a recipes
integration the tidy models recipes
so you have if you are familiar with
recipes you have all these step
functions
and there is a new step pre-trained text
embedding
and you can just plug out a text
a pre-trained text model for example
oh sorry
for example here it's a pre-trained
model in the google news data set
which is which is a very large data set
of
news and it will
convert broad text to a feature vector
that
you can just use in your machine
learning model
and then you can fit a logistic
regression for example
using this feature vector
um okay in
cairns we have these new text
pre-processing layers
well uh if you it starts in tf
2.0.1 sorry
and it changes like
the before the keras pre-processing
functions
are all based in scipy and numpy
so you needed to to have a
in order to use the functions in cairos
you needed
also to have a python
to deploy models that used text
pre-processing functioning cares you
needed to have a python
runtime and now they are building in the
tensorflow
graph so you you can build models
uh using this layer text vectorization
and the deployment
will be much easier so it it works
just like a normal keras layer you
define what are the the main
parameters and there's a new step called
adapt which will for example find
all different words in your text data or
it will do all the it will find the
maximum length of each
text and things like this and then you
can just plug this layer
in the in your keras model like
so you your model will input strings
and you just plug like a normal
keras model
another cool new package by secret
is tf probability which allows which
provides a lot of statistical
computation and
probability probabilistic functions
it's built on top of tensorflow so it's
it provides gpu and cpu and even tpu
implementation for most things which
great
and fast and
i want to show you just this
layer distribution function that you can
plug
in your keras model as an usual as
unusual keras layer and instead of
predicting a single
value for each observation you can for
example predict
a normal distribution for each
observation so you can calculate
uh standard deviation and and stuff
so this opens uh
a great scope for deep for deep learning
you can see more in the the release
blog post which is linked here
there is auto cares a package by juan
cruz
and it it interfaces
r to the auto carriers package in python
which does this auto ml
[Music]
which uses auto ml techniques to build
a machine learning models so instead of
defining all your cameras
layers and how they are connected you
can just use this
model image classifier and how many
different models you want to try and it
will
try to get a a a good model for
for your data set okay
there is tfds a new package
which is very experimental yet but it
allows you to load
uh public data sets
you in the tensorflow data sets format
which
for example you can load imagenet using
uh tfds without
touching all the i don't know 100
gigabytes
of images and how to download then where
and how to pre-process and everything so
it's
it's much easier to just test your
machine learning model
and it provides this split api
that you can say like i want to to
split my data in training validation and
test set directly
so it's a nice package when you are
learning
new new things
when you are trying your machine
learning your
deep learning model we are also
providing some model packages
which like we took
some commonly used deep learning models
and packaged
packages are
wrappers for them for example the gp2
package by
javier uraski and
it the gp2 model is is a
deep learning model by opening ais
which takes like a a prompt
string and it can like complete
this this
string with a text that really makes
sense and
it's pretty incredible
we also implemented some deep learning
models
using raw keras uh
layers just for uh
for so it's easier to learn and you can
see advanced
modeling code in keras so
there is unet which is a image
segmentation model
and densenet which is a convolutional
neural network
architecture that was famous like
maybe two years ago and deep learning is
very fast
and there are also community
contributed
models like the art bird
by jonathan and john harmon
which provides an implementation of the
birth model
which is a google model for text
embedding
we also have the tensorflow for our blog
which cigarette writes
many many articles showing the state of
the art of tensorflow
and deep learning with very detailed
explanations thank you
thank you very much and we've got a few
minutes for questions um
so one of the questions on slido is
classification and regression problems
are very accessible
via rs interface to tensorflow how about
survival
survival problems such as time to event
outcomes
search time to event outcomes
survival usually
deep learning is very flexible so you
this time to event uh models
can be just can be modeled by
by just changing your loss function so
you can cover this with uh
deep learning with the keras package
there's a there's a blog post by sigrid
that would use tensorflow probability or
the rep idea of probability
and that would be monte carlo modeling
to do that we have a blog post i think
it's called like
oh how is it called anyone else
censored data something yeah
things for data right you wrote this box
yeah and this uses
uh tensorflow probabilities so not deep
learning but also
cool stuff
what are our studio's plans to support
torch or pie torch
i don't know we we have worked
i have experimented with torch
the like a year ago with the c plus plus
api but
i'm not sure if we are going to move
forward torch
for now
well someone wants to know what are you
working on right now
yeah uh tensorflow is a large ecosystem
like we there's always a lot of stuff
that we
we want to work on like there's this
uh dopamine library for
for reinforcement learning which is
something we would like to work and
there's also a lot of work with tf
probabilities to you so
yeah all right one more um
is there is the plan to track the python
interface to tensorflow
or will the r extras mean that python
users won't recognize our base
tensorflow code
yeah like cares the
cares our package tries to
mean to keep track of all python changes
for example
these new text pre-processing layers and
there will be
image preprocessing layers and all this
kind of stuff
we we will try to always keep track of
the
of the care of the keras api but we like
to
add like uh our uh
their way of doing things also
like the features back interface which
doesn't exist in the
python implementation
excellent thank you so let's give
another round of applause